So, let's first take a look at planning for the control rig and some considerations to
make when you're thinking about how your mechanical mesh should be deforming.
So, it's useful to think of it as sort of rigid body versus organic skinning and thinking
about how each particular piece of the mesh needs to deform.
So mechanical meshes are typically rigid bodies and should be skinned to one bone each.
So, it's very likely that all of your mechanical meshes are broken into many different parts
and you know they're all connected and held together with screws and bolts and rivets
and they all have different pivot points.
So you want these solid parts to only be skinned to one bone so that they don't deform
in an unusual way and you know look all bendy when it's animating.
But that's not necessarily going to be true for every part of your skeletal mesh.
Things like springs should be weighted perfectly evenly between two bones so that when they
compress and contract they'll be deforming accurately.
And you may also have parts like cables or wires on your mesh that are carrying things
like hydraulic fluid or electrical cables and these obviously are going to need to deform
in a more organic way than this big chunk of solid metal.
So they may have several influences from different joints depending on you know how long they
are and how they might need to deform.
So it's really about considering and thinking how each part of the mesh needs to deform
and then just skinning them in the appropriate way to make the rigging in the engine a bit
more straightforward for yourself.
When it comes to orienting your bones it can be really helpful to orient them in the direction
of travel.
So typically we would use the X-axis to point down the bone in the direction that that mesh
would travel.
And this is just going to help speed up your rigging workflow in the engine.
So when you're thinking about things like pistons or any sort of telescopic type movement
being consistent with your axis that you're pointing down the bone can be really helpful.
And when it comes to meshes that act in the same way so like the tires of a car for example
they're all going to be rolling the same and sort of turning the same.
Setting up all of the bones with the same orientation and this could just be world orienting them
for example can be really helpful in simplifying the control rig logic again because you can
use the same logic for all of these tires instead of making sort of custom adjustments
per tire to account for any differences in their orientations.
Mirroring bone orientations by behavior can also be very helpful because if you have something
like a claw grabber that we have here we can set things up so that we can feed the same
logic into both bones and easily use one control to manipulate both of them.
So in this example with this sort of claw grabber that we have here the logic has been
set up so that we can move this teal colored controller left and right and as we do that
the claw will open and close without having to add any extra logic to account for the
differences in their orientation.
So we're just grabbing the transform values and converting it to rotations and feeding
that straight into the into the claw bones.
And there's only possible if you mirror by behavior.
Something that you might find with your skeleton hierarchy is that you end up having fewer
chains of bones and more individual children coming off a shed parent.
So in this example here we've got a car where we have a root and then each of the wheels
and the doors simply have a single bone to control those meshes.
And with this example of the suspension on the car chassis you can see that this rear
axle and everything that's fixed to it is a child of the same parent on the right here.
And that's because any meshes like suspension springs or damper arms here where each end
is fixed to a different mesh making those bones a child of the mesh that they're fixed
to is going to make things much easier when you're rigging an engine than if you had a
chain of bones here instead.
So with a mechanical rig you'll probably find that you have fewer chains of joints and more
single children coming from shed parents of the things that they're affixed to.